i gotta i've got sunshine all righty on
my shoulder right here oh
that's a song right no sunshine in your
pocket
we've also got a little extra humidity
in the air and i don't know if you've
been out yet to
walk the dog or maybe pick up the
newspaper if you have been then you'll
notice it
temperatures mostly in the 70s but west
valley neighborhoods have dropped just
barely into some upper 60s red rocks
still at 60 degrees not much in the way
of wind light variable winds boulder
city you're just down to 69 as well and
perhaps has some 60s in the front valley
we're all going to get a taste of this
smoke that's going to make its way back
from california and meander right into
southern nevada that's going to start
tonight into tomorrow and maybe even
linger into wednesday now as we roll the
smoke forecast we're also going to get
quite a bit of wind by tomorrow and
that's from a cold front moving through
the pacific northwest into the northern
rockies i don't think it'll make it all
the way through our area but just close
enough to open up the door for some
cooler temperatures and highs in the 80s
down to normal and even a little below
normal for a few days probably drag some
clouds through and we may even see some
showers again in parts of mohave county
northwest arizona to the east and maybe
north of us but not in southern nevada
boy we sure do need it too they are
going to get some rain in the pacific
northwest along that cold front but
unfortunately it's going to stir up some
very dry west southwest winds and some
increase in fire weather dangers for
western nevada up in the northern
rockies this is that low pressure system
that's really been spinning showers and
thunderstorms all around the four
corners and very close to clark county
but not getting any of that rain today
we'll be looking for sunshine above
normal temps in the mid 90s this will be
four days in a row we've hit 94 degrees
mainly just a very light southerly
breeze today but those winds will
increase out of the southwest
so tomorrow 25 maybe 30 mile an hour
winds no wind advisories and we'll also
get some clouds tomorrow night into
wednesday but definitely look for that
smoky haze late today into tonight and
tuesday temperatures drop into the 80s
mornings in the 60s that's going to feel
good and then we warm right back up to
low 90s again for the weekend